[Music]
are you guys doing really well thank you
both of you thank you so much for coming
in I I so appreciate it
the only reason I get to talk to you
guys and the only reason Collider gets
to be at the Toronto Film Festival it's
going to have great sponsors I want to
give a huge thank you to Nordstrom
Canada for allowing me to talk to you
guys you know sponsors are important
I'm sure they will very much appreciate
that
for both of you guys what there's a
million things I want to talk to you
about this but how how familiar were
both of you with Ned Kelly's story prior
to getting the script I know it's
generic but let's jump in with that um
well my dad's an Aussie my dad's from
Australia so I have growing up there had
been a long time since before before
making the film that I'd since I've been
to Australia to see my family but all my
cousins and aunt and uncle's are there
and I've spent quite a lot of time there
when I was much younger so I know that
Ned Kelly history from from then but
what I didn't know until kind of
researching this and reading Peter
Carey's book was was the it was his was
the fact he wasn't he was Irish and that
kind of like I kind of had taken for
granted their colonial history of
Australia to be frank and and that in
that sort of world and understanding of
that kind of Wild West and how that came
about because of the you know
Australia's recent colonial history is
that was sort of a new understanding
that came with you know reading Peters
book and then the factual history that
went with it afterwards but Ned Kelly is
a legend I knew of through my dad who's
you know who's an Aussie
I'd only through watching film I'd never
really done any research on him or you
know I hadn't read any any literature on
him so I'd seen a couple of past movies
it's funny I was watching I saw the film
a little while ago and since I watched
it really occurred to me just how
archetypal that story is you know and
you know they see that narrative played
out over and over that same story I was
watching
for instance animal kingdom and I
watched it within a week of watching
Kelly Gang it's virtually the same story
you know and it's a you know I'm sure we
will be asked presumably not by you
because you're smarter than that but why
make another why make it nothing that
Callie knows no sure how you see me
wouldn't but you know I think the answer
to that speaks for itself you know
people it's the same reason people watch
the same film over and over again
essential stories want to be told over
and over and people want to see that
those essential stories over and over I
realized something as I'm talking to the
two of you
I've talking to the two of you a lot at
the Toronto Film Festival so I have you
two decided to like get maybe you could
split like an apartment here and each of
you have it and like each other bedroom
or am I wrong about this no I just
recently put it to Charlie actually that
we could we could do that you know like
I sort of you know Austin Powers sort of
like Sims you know ostentatious
apartment the problem is they don't
think we could afford it in Toronto
anymore that that's the problem
I mean real estates just gone crazy here
right sure but build and they build and
they build maybe we could get a studio
look I'm just I'm just pointing out that
I'm sitting across from realizing it's
like the last few years I think I've
spoken
I know I've spoken to you up on sheer
you know I've spoken to you it's like
you know second home I was trying to
think about it on the plane I think I've
spent 16 months of my life in Toronto I
think that's probably what it works out
at so it's you know I didn't figure out
the percentage but that's got to be you
know three and a half four percent of my
life so there's a piece of my heart
belongs to Toronto yep but first of all
the city is amazing it's my favorite
Film Festival
they love movies weather everything
about it but okay jumping back into the
movie one of the things that's very
unique is the story structure it's like
three chapters and what was it like
reading that in the script I guess I'm
curious when you get the script what was
your first reaction and then if you
could talk about the structure of three
chapters well I guess well to start with
the script in general I mean like with
both we are both huge fan
of Justin's work I'm not just saying the
snow town I think is the most affecting
cinema experience I've ever had like
that and so the opportunity of working
with Justin and kind of knowing the sort
of world of his films and his kind of
assist aesthetic seems a bit
surface-level but that kind of the feel
of Justin's work kind of know it having
that in the back of my mind with then
reading Sean's amazing script as well
was just was just so exciting but in
terms of like the three like the three
act structure it's kind of I guess
that's like so typically like a play and
I think it's it's charting you know the
change within I guess obviously through
the spine of it you know you've got Ned
as Ned but it's the sort of versions of
him so to speak in a boy man monitor and
that sort of state stages of growth
essentially of a boy man the natural
growth and then sort of transcending
into something unnatural which is him
grasping a kind of an identity that he
is created that he's been given that
he's latching onto that's been applied
to him it's all of that like that's what
monitor is for me there are so many kind
of references as to you know it's like
the monitor lizzard the the monitor
battleship there like there was once
that there's a bit of Peter Carey's book
in an earlier draft of the script where
you know he was the ink monitor at
school and there was a kind of series of
bullying experiences that happen to him
then and it was just that so therefore
attach that word was responsibility and
a job and the sort of ink and blood for
words put like the penmanship everything
there's so many metaphors entwined in
that word and that I think that last act
is sort of when he transcends as to kind
of yeah as I said grabbing other
grabbing things to apply to himself and
accepting the things that are applied to
him but it's a less kind of biological
growth if you know what I mean
completely it seems it seems like we're
going through a period right now I'm
seeing a lot where we are distancing
ourselves as the filmmaking community
from the very traditional classic 120
page three at structures 30 page first
act 60 pages that connect 30 paid 30
page third act
seems that people are it's an
interesting trend going on right now it
seems that people are dispensing with
first act a lot you know the first step
set up that audiences have become so
smart and so savvy to storytelling into
filmmaking that a lot of the you know
the world creation and setting up is
sort of you know by Rao like penis I get
yeah we saw that we get that you know
and and so I think this this seems to me
like you know a slightly radical
transition going on in the filmmaking
community and I think this was sort of
an example of it I thought it was really
it sort of made me think a little bit of
moonlight and in the structure of this I
mean they I was really surprised when I
read the script cuz I don't you probably
remember better than me but the fruit it
was it about forty pages with young
nerds
yes a really long period of time we
spend with young lads in in the
screenplay now I think in the editing of
it Justin certainly does revert back to
a classical structure but they're having
the heavy heavily weighted first act got
truncated a little bit but you know I I
just I I did think they made some pretty
you know radical moves with with messing
with the with the architecture of this
thing to great effect you definitely
have to ask so when you're working I
can't remember did you did you have
scenes with Russell yes that was
different but you it seems with Russell
yeah I'm curious what is it is it hard
to not spend the entire day on set
talking about Master and Commander you
know I was playing a you know we have a
very contentious relationship in the
film Russell and I sure and I could I
just intuited that Russell's the type of
dudes he's gonna show up and take you
know take your measure and that's gonna
dictate a lot of how the experience with
him goes so I wanted to come in and try
to set a precedent that you know
there was gonna be two sides of this
dynamic and I might have overcompensated
a little bit can I swear on your net 100
hundred percent so Russell I guess was
going to do another project he put on a
little bit of weight and it was his
first day of filming and I'd already had
the luxury of shooting a little bit and
it's kind of a contentious scene and
Justin said you good Russell good
everything all right I said yeah I think
so and we've been improvising a lot as I
started to realize with Justin that's
the process you improvise a little bit
so I just decided we're gonna dispense
with the script and this first take and
I could I knew what I wanted to say or
an approximation of what I wanted to say
but I didn't know if I was gonna be able
to speak it because my heart was
pounding so hard in my chest but I
walked up on my horse stopped I had the
first line as saying oh you're back in
town or something like that and I said
you put on some weight you [ __ ] hunt and
this demon appeared in his eyes for a
second and I held it and then the humor
came through and not at anything and I
knew I'd made a friend you know it could
have gone one of two ways that was that
that is amazing and it takes [ __ ]
balls to do that with Russell Crowe I
mean come on
right I'm a thi the commander Lisin
master and commander is you know like
they make a lot of movies and they talk
about oh I hope we can make us like
sequels and everything else I would
actually pay real money for a Master and
Commander sequel I love that movie so
much it's so good it's so authentic and
real and exciting and you know it could
have the only thing that could have made
it better if I was in him I auditioned
three times so that film Oh for real
yeah it was a long process and obviously
you know we had the whole thing you know
I was very excited and the infancy of my
career but it was not to be right you
landed on your feet you're okay I'm all
right right but that's great like yeah
first of all thanks for sharing that
story that's great but for the
of you what is it I mean listen you both
worked in a bunch of things but what is
it like working opposite people that you
really really respect you know what I
mean and like that energy that comes
when you get to set with great people
you kind of like we've so blessed with
the you know with it with the cast and
the crew of this film and and you know
and working working for Justin is our
director I think in a way you've kind of
just got to go with the presence of a
situation in terms of your like you've
got except playing playing football or
something and if you know if you you get
you get a call-up for Chelsea and you're
kind of and if you were to get on the
pitch and be overawed with you know that
with the players that you're playing
amongst you'd be letting the team down
so it's kind of that thing of I think
trying to use those nerves just purely
as a motivator to be a bit like okay
what how can I best serve this situation
that how can I just you know you know
you want to be that one that you know
you just want you just wanted you just
want to do well basically but not kind
of worrying about ticking boxes and
being sort of you know worrying about if
you're gonna get it wrong and I think so
I I think in a way to answer your
question it's just it's just about kind
of letting go and just being you know
what's the best thing that you can do in
this situation is to kind of you can
appreciate it most by giving it your all
and then by the same token Justin's
process was so experimental and
inventive like our rehearsal process we
were like he saw the Kelly Gang as a
punk band and so we have about four
weeks rehearsal and us boys and Orlando
included who's he was played the amazing
young Ned um he said right you've got a
gig in Melbourne in three weeks in a bar
you got right a punk set and so most of
our rehearsals we go in and we'd write
songs punk songs and we played in a bar
and Melbourne just as we had to come up
with a name completely sort of incognito
it wasn't like the Kelly Gang sort of
thing it was just we had a we had our
own band and we we played in a bar in
Melbourne and and that but that kind of
thing of like it got everyone sharing
stories sharing writing sharing ideas
sharing like openers what was that whoo
and also just listening to each other
and also having that kind of punk
attitude as well because but you know by
week two we're like what we're pretty
[ __ ] good I can't wait to play this
gig you know smashing away and like
would we'd get in dresses every day
but as we gots the production office we
put dresses on so we get used to walking
around and feeling masculine in a dress
and like I'm wearing that as our armor
you know and kind of going into the
rooms and not being afraid to be you
know and I was in this kind of slightly
see-through yellow dress for although
the rehearsals smashing away at this
guitar and that kind of like I don't
know it puts your head in a different
gear so you're not thinking about who
your unset with necessarily you're just
kind of in or in the zone of it and
that's that stanza just that's actually
very interesting and cool process um I
actually because I know I'm gonna run
out of time with you guys soon actually
let's switch subjects for a quick second
I love as you can tell by my t-shirt I
love Roger Deakins love want to stress
these words I know that you I believe
you just worked with Roger what was that
process like it was absolutely
incredible and Roger is a true gentleman
and I and I guess the only thing we say
this like I mean it was it was truly
wonderful but just in terms of shifting
subject back I think in terms of film
this this the Kelly Gang has not got
much money behind it and we're kind of
here to give it as biggest push as
possible when 19:17 does have a bit more
kind of like financial backing so I kind
of if we could twist it back to Kelly
Gang that'd be amazing sure thank you
sorry elegant but firm yeah I
anytime I talk to people who work with
Roger I always like having them share
stories just because you know what I
mean and of course what is it like
watching I can you guys watch yourself
on screen or do you like when you go to
look the premiere of a movie like this
do you introduce the movie and then like
immediately walk out or you know what I
mean cuz I've heard some people just go
to dinner and then they come back for
the Q&A yeah I mean it's a dangerous
game you can have really wonderful
experiences watching a film with an
audience you'll have had this experience
I'm sure dozens of times it's remarkable
how how differently a film can play with
different audiences on different nights
I've been I only did this with one film
but I went and saw it three nights or
three different audiences and the
experience was
you know categorically different every
time the lost city of that yeah it's
kind of good I watched it
dude I watched it in England at the
national in London in the National
History Museum with the like Uppercross
of a cross sort of creme de la creme of
English society and it was like being in
a [ __ ] funeral I walked out of that
screening and had to walk for an hour
before I could go to the after-party
that my entire family was waiting for me
because I just was crying I just thought
what happened I I thought I was proud of
my work I thought this is a good film
and it literally was like being an awake
being in that you know there's no
participations no and I could tell
people didn't like the film as they
walked out and it was it was for me I
was quite vulnerable of at that time
because King Arthur come out and just
absolutely [ __ ] the bed and I just
thought I don't know what to do how what
what do you do so so yeah I try to avoid
watching films and screenings because it
can you know say I just I was in Tokyo
earlier this year and I was in an
auditorium watching the premiere of
Godzilla Godzilla sequel and I was next
to kids and it was a packed theater and
it was silent and that is the way they
watch movies in Tokyo they don't clap
they don't react and it is and that's
their sign of respect and but I mean I
was with little kids who were silent I'm
like how do you do this man you know
what I mean
but just to say something the city is he
is [ __ ] awesome
so I mean like you know it's it's
fragile you know you put yourself out
there you vulnerable that week you know
and so and you know you do travel a lot
your travel and then you build up to the
week you finally go to the premiere and
you're invariably tired and emotion like
little emotionally oversensitive and it
can be tough so have you said that I'm
gonna go watch because I really want to
see it with an audience um I really have
to stop there and say Cersei Congrats on
the movie thank you both so much for
coming in and I wish you guys both
nothing but the best and I also can't
wait to see the gentlemen because that
movie looks amazing